So let's actually apply this to our real
example that we've been talking about in this
lesson, blood type and the ABO enzyme. So this is the ABO gene here and it's
transcribed into the ABO mRNA that you see
here. Now obviously you'll notice that the mRNA
copy is much shorter than the ABO gene
itself. And you'll also notice that exons and
introns can come in all different shapes and sizes.
They can be really big or really short. And they
don't have to be the same size even within a
gene. So without me making it explicit and telling you
exactly where all the introns and exons are. I want
you to tell me, what do you think is most
likely an intron in this image? Do you think its
this big orange segment here? This smaller purple segment here?
This dash black region out here, or this bigger purple section here?
Go ahead and select the answer that you think represents most likely an intron.